it was the very last opportunity for
Brazil's presidential candidates to
appeal to undecided voters
far-right incumbent president Jade
bolsonaro put the emphasis on
conservative Family Values opposition to
sexual diversity and to abortion
Al polls were Watchdog for bolsonaro at
the polls keep your eyes wide open to
see everything that's going on
for the South his left-wing rival former
president Lula da Silva appealed to
Brazilians not to believe what he called
a Shameless disinformation campaign
against him
I am 77 years old and I've never seen a
factory capable of producing so many
lies as our current president
Brazil is the world's fourth largest
democracy and for the first time in half
a century many worry about that
democracy's future
School teachers Denise and Gilberto
pantrona play their favorite Brazilian
music as they consider leaving their
country should bolsonaro be re-elected
Society is this there is a
there is a racism
tolerance or arrival on the scene has
revealed a Savage Trend that's come to
the surface and that makes us very sad
has repeatedly been attacking the
Electoral Court suggesting there could
be fraud if he loses
yes he can follow the same passion Trump
used in the United States with the
occupation of the capital apparently
there are signs on this direction but
unlike Trump bolsonaro has the support
of the security forces
another concern is bolsonaro's vow if
re-elected to change the composition of
the Supreme Court the only institution
which he and his allies no longer
dominate
when one wants to change democracy for
our autocracy the system fails and it is
these flaws that the current president
bolsonaro wants to take advantage of
because he evidently wants to transform
himself into an autocrat
but opponents of Lula are equally
concerned about democracy they say they
fear he will turn Brazil into a
dictatorship citing the left-wing
candidates apparent support for the
leaders of Venezuela Cuba and Nicaragua
whoever wins Brazil appears to be
divided in half and people on both sides
of the Divide are increasingly viewing
the other not as an adversary but as an
enemy a dangerous phenomena for Brazil's
democracy
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Sao Paulo